I'm Chief superintendent Karen Edwards
I'm the divisional Commander at West
Division in Lancashire
you'll be aware that yesterday evening a
young child was involved in a collision
with a police vehicle in Lancaster
I want to give you an update a bit
before I go into the detail the most
important thing that I want to say today
is that my thoughts and prayers remain
with a little boy and his family
the Collision happened just before 8 30
p.m on Owen Road in Lancaster
at the junction with tourist Home Road
and it involved a marked police per show
308 hatchback which was responding to an
emergency call
the boy who is 11 years old from the
local area
was taken by ambulance to the Royal
Lancaster Infirmary
it was later transferred to older hey
Children's Hospital in Liverpool
he remains in a critical condition
as I said our thoughts are with his
loved ones at this time
they've been supported by our specially
trained officers
now I appreciate there'll be lots of
questions about what has happened and
why
and I want to reassure you today that a
full and thorough investigation will be
carried out to establish the
circumstances
as you will appreciate this is now
subject to a live investigation
so I'm unable to provide additional
detail at this time
last night we have referred the matter
to the independent office for police
conduct the iopc
and they'll be carrying out an
independent investigation
we will of course cooperate fully with
them
I want to take this opportunity to thank
our local communities in Lancaster and
across Lancashire and wider for their
understanding and support
[Music]
during what has clearly been a hugely
distressing incident
I have placed extra reassurance Patrols
in and around the area today and over
the weekend
and anyone with information or concerns
should feel free to approach and speak
to my officers
finally
anyone with information
CCTV or dash cam footage that may assist
the investigation is asked to contact
I'm grateful for you coming today thank
you very much for your time thank you